that's why I say hello hey guys I'm
currently in Perth Australia I'm here
doing me no filter show tour with Hannah
Hart and mamrie Hart we're currently on
tour doing the no filter show here in
Australia and we have one show left in
Perth which is like I said where I am
Bret sounds really adorable like it
should be really cute little like
boutique e-town and then you get here in
it's Perth great big fan I'm doing a Q&A
video today because I went on my
Facebook page because I use Facebook and
I asked you guys for questions and I'm
gonna answer them right now so let's get
into answers here we go are you doing a
book tour in 2016 will you please come
to Austin I can say that yes there will
be a book tour for the book that I have
currently available for presale grace
and style the art of pretending you have
it my new style guide that you can get
at grey style book calm I cannot give
you details of the book tour just yet
because they are not completely finished
but when they are finished I will tell
you in so much detail meaning the most
minimal amount of things I can say
before I give you incorrect information
how would you feel if secretly goose was
your owner instead of you being hurt I
would feel exactly as I feel now because
that is the reality of our relationship
I'm very beta you guys you betta believe
it
I'm very passive how do you feel about
people putting reindeer antlers on their
cars adorable and dangerous no it's
actually I lied it's not adorable
I'm noxious and dangerous my mom does it
sometimes I love you mom but your car is
a car not a reindeer which vegetable
causes you the most anger the eggplant
it acts so unassuming but that eggplant
knows how to find a Christmas present
for your boss not an eggplant
maybe my style book though great style
book calm its the eggplant of style
books
so who TD I'm be excited for Grayson
style so feel free to use this question
as a book club hey I will use this
question as a book plug and that was a
butt plug butt plugs out book plugs in
more trend tips like that in my style
book grace table book calm this shirt is
from Topshop these pants are from Zara
these feet were created by both of my
parents consummating their relationship
what was your favorite thing in 2015 and
what are you looking forward to in 2016
2017 was a really great year and also a
year of a lot of self-reflection for me
and it makes me very excited for 2016
because I want to try to do things a
little differently I don't want to feel
routine with anything that I'm doing I
think in 2015 I got into a moment of
time where I felt like I was just
putting things out into the universe on
a creative level that I felt passable
but not my best so I really want to
challenge myself in 2016 to create
things that I am surprised by I'm
surprised by that as ik come down
shoulders what are three things that you
need before you hit the stage what are
three things I need before I hit the
stage to do live stuff let's see I need
a good pump up song or something that
really gets the blood flowing in my body
and my brain I need a group hug from
Hannah and mamrie if we are performing
together if I'm performing by myself
I need some sort of positive
reinforcement from the people around me
and I need an open mind or like hummus
both of those things can make very
unpredictable moments and Jos thoughts
on Anna Kendrick all the time who makes
you laugh the most
my younger brother Tim usually makes me
laugh but most when I'm around him I
haven't been around him that much this
year but I will get to see him over the
holiday so hopefully I'll get to film
him whether he wants to be filmed or not
because that's the kind of relationship
we have at least
from my perspective and definitely not
mutually shared by both of us but that's
okay because I'm older so there is some
sort of like unspoken rule that I'm
allowed to exploit him without his
permission so that's cool yeah he makes
me laugh
what can we expect from your Sabbath a
good laugh or a new wardrobe both
unexpected style tips you can expect
unexpected personal stories from me and
you can expect unexpected photography
what are you doing for New Year's I have
no idea I have no idea none whatsoever
zero what are you doing Wow humble brag
okay congratulations that's a lie
are you okay you good how are you how
many noodles the answer to all of that
is yeah favorite things is about
Australia you guys are so incredibly
nice and you are basically like a parody
of yourselves I knew that you guys were
I had heard that Australians are very
nice and you guys have proven yourselves
extremely extremely nice and all the
shows that we've done here have been so
wonderful because it really seems like
you guys are having a great time and we
have the most fun when you guys are
having fun what was the last lie you
told probably like every answer to every
question in this video great style book
that Kyle I don't know how do you feel
about this picture it's a lot it's a lot
it's it's a lot it's a lot and like the
person taking this photo knew it was a
lot like they knew it they knew this was
like too much
like this is a lot just like fondue like
I'm see yeah so fun quirky everyone will
love it and then like five minutes into
it you're like wow
ouch arteries ouch